und wir nehmen das ergebnis auch an auch
mit demut und wir waren aus dem ergebnis
auch lehren ziehen müssen wir müssen
genau analysieren
herr huber für was wurde die csu heute
von den wählern abgestraft
da gibt es eine ganze fülle von punkten
es war einmal der stil der politischen
diskussion der letzten jahre
das ist natürlich die verkorkste
bundespolitik mit einem halben jahr und
da haben wir zu wenig auch die
befindlichkeit der menschen in den
großstädten wahrgenommen wenn die umwelt
und klimaschutz gemacht das heißt also
wir haben schon jeden anlass eine ganz
gründliche analyse zu machen
diese gründliche analyse wird
wahrscheinlich auch personen betreffen
wer trägt denn ihrer meinung nach die
verantwortung für dieses ergebnis
wir können uns nur die reaktion aus der
csu heraus dokumentieren also jetzt
nicht meine meinung und da höre ich nur
solidarität und anerkennung und lob für
markus söder
die csu ist am eingang hatte im
wahlkampf vor allem auch in den letzten
monaten ganz hervorragend gekämpft hat
ja nun auch umgestellt
die die
strategie gegen greift die wir sind ja
seit juli frontal und ihr euch die
angegangen das hat wirkung gezeigt
das heißt also in der csu gibt es volle
rückendeckung für markus söder und alles
andere müssen welchen weiteren
diskussionen über lassen inwiefern war
es dann ein fehler die afg erst dann im
sommer richtig anzugehen
also dem liegt eine falsche analyse
zugrunde was irgendwann im
parteivorstand auch darüber mal hat
diskutiert horst seehofer der meinung
wir verlieren nur nach rechts und diese
aussage von strauß rechts von uns darf
es keine demokratisch legitimierte
partei geben hat ihn dazu gebracht zu
sagen wir wir schulen die afg aber wir
versuchen die themen zu besetzen das war
die strategie aber durchaus überlegt
aber falsch ich glaube einmal das
hochziehen das thema flüchtlinge asyl im
letzten halben jahr nachdem das
eigentlich gar nicht so violent war war
falsch das war wasser auf die mühlen der
afg und insgesamt muss man in den
völkischen rechtsradikalen
rechtsextremistischen kern da ich die
offen regeln damit nicht so aus ein wort
test position
diese partei wählen also der einstieg
wird weiterhin und so
bevorzugte gegner sein aber wir müssen
zugleich auch die wähler der mitte
wieder gewinnen
auch durch diese fixierung auf das thema
flüchtlinge auch die oft sehr harte
aussagen menschen die human- und
christlich solidarisch eingestellt sind
eher verschreckt durch diese hat die
politik und es wird uns nicht leicht
fallen jahr wieder zu gewinnen das heißt
also wenn ich es würde uns nicht gleich
gemacht werden
wir müssen uns sehr anstrengen denn wir
haben sehr viele wähler an die freien
wähler und die grünen auch verloren
das heißt also das großstädtische
publikum fühlt sich bei der csu im
lebensgefühl nicht mehr ein
wir haben ein defizit was frauen dass
man jährigen frau und politik angeht und
vor allem also auch ein defizit im
bereich klima und umwelt und das muss
man sehr viel mehr als in der
vergangenheit in den mittelpunkt stehe
jetzt den blick auf ihre eigene
biografie in der csu
dieses ergebnis ist ja schlechter als
das ergebnis für das sie personelle
konsequenzen ziehen mussten welche
stellen sie sich jetzt vor
für die beiden die jetzt da vorne dran
sind für das duo das duo ist wie es
damals sie unter beckstein waren also
dass du süßer seehofer ist ein anderes
als dass du beckstein huber ja muss ich
mich gut verstanden haben zusammen
gearbeitet
ich habe in der tat von mir aus die
konsequenzen gezogen mit dem ergebnis
von 43 6 prozent
weil ich damit eine erneuerung der csu
in die wege leiten wollte obwohl ich da
erst 62 jahre alt feiern und ich habe
dann gesagt ich gehe in die zweite reihe
und wird gegen die zweiten reihe wie die
csu aber das muss jeder selber
entscheiden
ich glaube das ist jetzt falsch wäre
einfach eindrücklich zu fordern
denn das verdeckt dann hier die wahren
probleme die wir besprochen
ich glaube es geht sehr viel mehr darum
dass wir inhaltlich aufarbeiten und du
musst die offenheit 1000 muss noch den
stil der politik ändern
die glaubwürdigkeit die ernsthaftigkeit
das muss wieder im mittelpunkt des des
arbeitens von csu-politikern sehen das
anders da jetzt noch mal nachhaken also
erstmal keine personellen konsequenzen
das ist jeder selber gefordert darüber
nachzudenken
dankeschön